Und wie groß sind Sie, Herr Schuss?
Ich bin 1,85 Meter groß.
1,85 Meter groß.
Ja. Herr Schuss, was kann ich für Sie tun? Was führt Sie zu uns?
Also ich komme heute zu Ihnen, weil ich sehr, sehr schwer Luft bekomme.
Seit wann haben Sie Arterie Not?
Also das geht schon seit einer Woche, aber heute ist es besonders schlimm.
Seit zwei Tagen ist es sehr, sehr schlimm.
Seit zwei Tagen.
Und haben diese Beschwerden langsam oder plötzlich begonnen?
Also die haben langsam begonnen.
Langsam begonnen.
Und sind die Beschwerden dauerhaft oder gehen sie auch wieder weg?
Die sind die ganze Zeit da.
Können Sie bitte Sie sich das beschreiben?
Gibt es bestimmte Auslöse für diese Beschwerden?
Zum Beispiel mit Beantreten?
Wenn ich mich bewege, habe ich sehr, sehr starke Luftnot.
Ich muss stark husten.
Ich muss auch immer spucken.
Das ist für mich sehr, sehr anstrengend momentan.
Fühlen Sie sich diese Atemnot in Ruhe auch oder noch mal belastet?
Ich habe auch in Ruhe Atemnot, ja.
Aber wenn ich mich belastet, habe ich noch schlimmer.
Sind diese Beschwerden mittlerweile schlimmer oder besser geworden?
Seit zwei Tagen sind sie sehr schlimm geworden.
Sie haben gesagt, dass ich husten habe.
Haben Sie noch Ausruf bemerkt?
Ja, ich habe auch Ausruf.
Was ist die Farbe des Ausrufs?
Er ist glasig, aber auch ein bisschen gelb.
Seit wann haben Sie husten und Ausruf?
Wie bitte?
Seit zwei Tagen verwerfen.
Das hat alles vor einer Woche angefangen.
Aber seit zwei Tagen ist es schlimmer.
Wie ist die Konsistenz des Ausrufs?
Eitrig, also dickflüssig.
Eitrig und nicht flüssig.
Haben Sie Fieber bemerkt?
Kein Fieber.
Haben Sie Herzrasen?
Herzstupfen?
Herzrasen auch.
Und wenn Sie wollen, Herr Schulz, haben Sie gleichzeitig Schmerzen?
Brustschmerzen oder ein Gegerübnis?
Durch das husten habe ich sehr starke Brustschmerzen.
Aber sind die Schmerzen stehend, sehend oder drückend?
Also stechende Schmerzen habe ich.
Stehende Schmerzen?
Stehende Schmerzen aus?
In der Brust habe ich die hier, an den Seiten.
In der Rippe habe ich Schmerzen.
Rippeschmerzen, aber sie strellen nie aus.
Nicht rücken, Rippen, Schmerzen.
Wie stark sind die Schmerzen auf einer Schmerzstelle?
Von eins bis zehn vorbei.
Eins leichter und zehn unerträgliche Schmerzen sind.
Also fünf, sechs und Schmerz.
Ich möchte hier kurz unterbrechen,
unser Aufnahmegespräch.
Ich warte auf, ob Sie Brustschmerzen haben.
Aber jetzt kann ich Ihnen einen Saustoff geben.
Das wäre gut, wenn ich eine Saustoffe bekommen würde.
Diese Beschwerden werden dadurch ein bisschen schwerer sein.
Sie haben gesagt, dass Sie Brustschmerzen haben.
Rippenschmerzen.
Leiden Sie unter, in den letzten Seiten Gliederschmerzen,
auch Kopfschmerzen oder Erkenntungssymptome?
Ja, keine Erkenntungssymptome.
Müssen Sie nachts häufig wegen Atem nicht aufwachen?
In den letzten zwei Tagen, ja.
Was wird denn...
Ich muss oft hinsetzen.
Wenn Sie hinsetzen und...
Dann geht es mir besser, weil ich liege, ist schwierig.
Ich muss oft hinsetzen, damit ich Luft bekomme.
Wie viele Kissen brauchen Sie zum Schlafen?
Normalerweise eins, aber in den letzten zwei Tagen,
muss ich mit Oberkörperhochlagerung schlafen.
Gibt es in Ihrer Familie oder in Ihrem Umfeld
Personen mit ähnlichen Beschwerden?
Nein.
Wie schlafen Sie?
Normalerweise, aber ich meinte,
seit zwei Tagen schlafen Sie nicht gut, aber früher.
War ganz okay, habe ich keine Beschwerden gehabt.
So stark noch nie.
Und waren Sie in einem anderen Arzt?
Mal kurz.
Ja, in den letzten zwei Tagen.
Ich war noch nicht ausgeregt.
Sind Ihnen die Schwerst-Ausbrüche bemerkt?
Nein.
Und...
War Ihnen Schwindel?
Ja, ich atme sehr schnell,
und dann habe ich auch Schwindel.
Ich muss sehr schnell atmen.
Ich habe bemerkt, dass meine Atemfrequenz sehr hoch ist.
Haben Sie in letzter Zeit Ab- oder Zugelungen?
Gleichgeblieben.
Ungewollt, oder?
Haben Sie Probleme beim Stuhlgang oder bei Massalassen?
Nein.
Haben Sie keine Veränderung beim Stuhlgang oder bei Massalassen bemerkt?
Und...
Gibt es eine andere Beschwerde, die Sie hinzufügen möchten?
Weiß ich jetzt nicht.
Weiß ich jetzt nicht ganz genau.
Ja, und...
Gibt es wichtige Vorerkrankungen in Ihrer Erkrankungsschichte, von denen ich wissen sollte?
Ja, ich habe eine Lungenerkrankung.
Eine Lungenerkrankung.
Lungenerkrankung.
Ja, welche Erkrankung?
Ich habe eine COPD.
Eine COPD.
Seit wann haben Sie COPD?
Ich habe das schon seit 10 Jahren.
Und gibt es noch andere Krankheiten?
Nein.
Und wurden Sie schon mal operiert?
In meiner Kindheit ist der Blinddarm entführt worden, aber sonst nicht.
Fertig die Operation? Komplikationlos, oder?
Das ist jetzt schon über...
Erinnern Sie sich nicht, ja.
Ich war alles okay, überlegt.
Und gibt es noch?
Gibt es noch was?
Operationen oder...
Nein.
Und nehmen Sie regelmäßig oder bei Bedarf Medikamente ein?
Ja, stimmt.
Ein Spray für meine Lunge rein.
Wie heißt das?
Ich habe den Namen vergessen, leider.
Kann sein, dasselbe Tumor?
Ja, das nehme ich bei Bedarf ein, wenn ich als Notfallmedikament.
Ich habe noch eins, aber das habe ich den Namen vergessen.
Nur ein Medikament, nur ein Spray.
Genau, einmal am Tag nehme ich das an.
Einmal am Tag.
Rachen Sie, Herr Schulz?
Ja.
Seit wann rachen Sie?
Ich rauche schon sehr lange, fast 55 Jahre.
Mit 55 oder seit 55?
Also 55 Jahre lang.
Ich habe mit dem Medikament angefangen.
Das ist ja sehr viel.
Und wie viele Zigaretten rachen Sie am Tag?
Ich habe jetzt ein bisschen reduziert.
Ungefähr 10 bis 12 Zigaretten am Tag.
Und trinken Sie Alkohol?
Ja, ab und zu.
Wie viele trinken Sie am Tag?
Also ich trinke jetzt nicht jeden Tag, aber jeden dritten, vierten Tag trinke ich gerne Bier.
Herr Schulz, ich muss das fragen, das ist eine routinmäßige Frage.
Konsumieren Sie Drogen oder früher haben Sie Kontakt zu Drogen gehabt?
Ich habe noch nie harte Drogen genommen, nein.
Reagieren Sie auf bestimmte Medikamente oder Lebensmittel oder Substanzen allergisch?
Das ist mir nicht bekannt.
Sind Ihre Eltern noch am Leben?
Nein, beide verstorben.
Woran sind Sie verstorben?
Ja, mein Vater war krank, der hatte auch was an der Lunge.
Und meine Mutter hatte eine Dementio.
Und meine Mutter hatte eine Lunge gehabt und meine Mutter hat an einer Demenz verstorben.
Ihren Vater, woran leidet er?
Er hatte eine Lungenerkrankung gehabt, ich weiß aber nicht welche.
Wann ist er verstorben?
Ich war 25 Jahre.
Das ist 1980 Jahre.
Ich bin nicht ganz sicher, wer es tat.
Meine Mutter ist alt geworden, sie ist 2005 verstorben.
Sie hatte eine Demenz.
Haben Sie Geschwister?
Ich habe ein Einzelkind.
Sind Sie verheiratet?
Wie ist Ihr Familienstand?
Ich bin verheiratet.
Und haben Sie Kinder?
Ja, wir haben vier Kinder.
Sind Sie beide gesund?
Vier Kinder, alle gesund.
Also vier Kinder, alle gesund.
Und was machen Sie beruflich?
Ich bin Rettner.
Was haben Sie früher gemacht?
Ich bin LKW-Frau.
Haben Sie Hashtöne?
Nein.
Sagen Sie, Sie waren letztens im Ausland?
Nein, wir waren nicht im Ausland.
Wir waren nur mit meiner Frau zum Urlaub in einem Spa.
Wir waren ein Wochenende weg gewesen, letztes Wochenende.
Sie waren am Spa, oder?
Am Wochenende, meine Frau.
Haben Sie oder sind Ihre Beine manchmal angeschwollen?
Nein.
Ich möchte Ihre Beschwerden zusammenfassen.
Wenn Sie etwas hinzufügen, können Sie mich bitte beschweren.
Sie haben sehr viele Schmerzen.
Ich habe viele Schmerzen.
Seit einem Woche Atemnot.
Sie bekommen nicht ruhig Luft.
Aber seit zwei Tagen besonders.
Seit heute sind die Beschwerden schlimmer geworden.
Seit zwei Tagen, genau.
Seit zwei Tagen.
Sie sind langsam aufgetreten, aber dauerhaft.
Sie haben bemerkt, dass diese Beschwerden belastungsabhängig sind.
Fühlen Sie sich in Ruhe?
Ja, fühlen Sie sich das in Ruhe auch.
Gleichzeitig oder begleitend leiden Sie unter Hüsten.
Sie haben mit Auswurf gelbliche und eidrige Auswurf bemerkt.
Sie sind flüssig.
Sie leiden unter Herzrasen und Schmerzen.
Besonders Rippenschmerzen.
Sie leiden unter keine Erkennungssymptome.
Sie brauchen seit zwei Tagen viele Kissen zum Schlafen.
Ich muss aufstehen.
Sie müssen in der Nacht häufig aufwachen.
Sie haben keine Fieber bemerkt.
Gibt es noch andere Beschwerden, die Sie hinzufügen möchten?
Eigentlich nicht, nein.
Ich möchte das noch fragen.
Wann treten diese Beschwerden auf?
In der Nacht oder tagsüber?
Welche?
Hüsten, Auswurf.
Beides, sowohl als auch.
Und mehr, wenn ich mich belaste.
Danke schön Herr Schuss.
Ich habe meine Frage gestellt.
Wenn Sie wollen, können wir unsere Untersuchung durchführen.
Nach der Ergebnisse können wir über Ihre Beschwerden sprechen.
Alles klar, machen wir so.
Jetzt machen wir ein Arzt-Arzt-Gespräch.
Dann können Sie den Patienten vorstellen.
Ich möchte den Arzt-Gespräch anregen.
Gibt es weitere Fragen?
Ja, darf ich?
Haben Sie Heiserkeit?
Nein.
Haben Sie Beine Schwellung?
Haben wir gefragt, nein.
Ich habe eine Frage.
Bitte schön.
Letzte Zeit haben Sie ein Abodass zu genommen.
Haben wir gefragt, nein.
Murat, Sie haben die Dichtflüssigkeit.
Darf ich?
Bitte schön.
Würde Ihnen ein Herzkatheter durchgeführt?
Nein.
Danke schön.
Haben Sie zwei Enlihebeschwerden?
Bitte?
Haben Sie Enlihebeschwerden?
Ja, früher habe ich das immer gehabt.
Aber das war nicht so schlimm.
Waren Sie beim Hausarzt?
Damals, ja.
Würden Sie damals eine Diagnose festgestellt?
Ich habe einen Spray bekommen.
Welchen Namen?
Ich habe vergessen.
Darf ich fragen?
Bitte.
Sie haben erwähnt, dass Sie Herzrasen haben.
Schlag Ihr Herz unregelmäßig?
Nein, regelmäßig.
Danke schön.
Dann fangen wir an mit dem Arzt-Arztgespräch.
Ich muss mich heute ein bisschen beeilen.
Guten Tag Herr Chefarzt.
Ich möchte Ihnen heute unsere neuen Patienten vorstellen.
Nein, ich möchte Ihnen unsere neuen Patienten
Herrn Andres Schulz vorstellen.
Wenn Sie Zeit haben, kann ich anfangen.
Sehr gerne, bitte schön.
Es handelt sich um Herrn Andres Schulz.
Er ist 69 Jahre alt.
Er ist am 5. April 1956 geboren.
Er ist 79 Kilogramm schwer und 1,85 Meter groß.
Der Patient schützte sich bei uns wegen
seit zwei Tagen bestehende Dauerhafte.
Er schützte sich bei belastungsabhängigen Dismähen
sowie Tussis mit gelblichem und eitrigen Spurtung vor.
Der Patient berichtete, dass diese Beschwerden
seit einem Woche bestehen,
aber seit zwei Tagen sind verschlimmer geworden.
Der Patient verspürt Atemnot in Ruhe auf.
Er klagt über Tachycardi und Ortopne.
Die Fragen nach Fieber, Schüttelfrost,
Gewichtverlust und Wurdenverneid
Er schläft in letzter Zeit nicht gut
wegen Atemnot oder Dismähen.
In der Vorgeschichte zeigten sich COPD seit 10 Jahren.
Der Patient benutzt dagegen Spray,
aber er erinnert sich nicht der Name.
Er hat sich in der Kindheit eine Apparate
und eine Apandöktomie untersorgt.
Bei ihm gibt es keine bekannten Allergien.
In der Familienanamnese ist der Vater
wegen der Erkrankung verstorben.
Die Mutter ist an dem Mann mit 7.005 verstarben.
7.005?
7.005.
2.000.
2.005 verstarben.
Er ist ein Einzelkind.
Er ist verheiratet und lebt seine Frau.
Er hat vier Kinder.
Alle Kinder sind gesund.
Er ist Rentner.
Er hat früher als RKW-Fahrer gearbeitet.
Er hat keine Haustüre.
In der Reiseanamnese gibt es keine Auffälligkeiten
bis auf eine Urlaub am Wochenende im Spa.
War er schon beim Hausarzt?
Ja, er war vor einer Woche beim Hausarzt.
Ich meine, im aktuellen Fall.
Haben Sie ihn gefragt?
Ja, aber ich konnte ihn nicht finden.
Ja, ich kann ihn nicht finden.
Ja, dann ist das so.
Möchten Sie etwas noch fragen?
Möchten Sie etwas dazu fügen?
Was glauben Sie, was er hat?
Was denken Sie, was er hat?
Welche Diagnose?
Welche Differenzialdiagnosen?
Bei ihm wurde eine Zäopäte festgestellt.
Deswegen gehe ich von Verdacht auf eine Zäopäte-Exerserbation aus.
Die Analysten angeben, dass sie auf eine Zäopäte-Exerserbation gehen.
Und als Differenzialdiagnose kommen sie in eine Asthmaattac und Pneumonie.
Eine Pneumonie ist richtig, kann sein.
Hat aber keine Fieber.
Ja.
Eine vielleicht atypische Pneumonie.
Was könnte noch sein?
Ein kurzer Pornozid kann sein oder Lungenödeme oder Herzinsuffizienz.
Könnte sein Lungenembolie sein?
Die Beschwerden sind langsam aufgetreten.
Deswegen dachte ich das nicht so.
Genau.
Könnte sein Pneumotorax sein?
Ich habe nicht gefragt, ob er einen Unfall gehabt hat.
Muss er einen haben?
Nein, hemorrhagisch.
Spontan kann ein Pneumotorax sein.
Aber das kann sein.
Er hat Brustschmerz.
Er hat ja Rippenschmerzen erzählt.
Ja, Rippenschmerzen.
Was machen Sie denn diagnostisch, um die Diagnose zu rechtfertigen?
Ich würde zuerst eine ausführliche körperliche Untersuchung durchführen.
Wir können die Inspektion, die Perkussion kontrollieren.
Und die Laborwerte können wir noch prüfen.
C-RP, einige Einzündungsparameter, wie C-RP, BSG und Elektrolyt.
Das ist ein Blutbild, das wir noch kontrollieren können.
Und eine Röntgen-Torax kann ich antworten.
Und danach CT und immer Angio.
Was machen Sie vorher, bevor Sie Blut abnehmen?
Bevor Sie Röntgenbild machen?
Die Vitalparameter müssen kontinuiert werden.
Was gehört zu den Vitalparametern?
Atomfrequenz, Herzfrequenz und Blutdruck messen.
EKG schreiben haben Sie ausgemacht?
Was müssen Sie noch machen bei diesen Patienten?
Was dürfen Sie nicht vergessen?
Eine Begehrung?
Blutgasanalyse.
Wissen Sie, was das ist?
C-UPD-Patienten und Luftnot müssten immer eine Blutgasse haben.
Ja, Blutgasanalyse müssen wir kontrollieren.
Um arterielle Sauerstoffsättigung zu prüfen,
müssen wir die Blutgasanalyse bei den Patienten mit C-UPD kontrollieren.
Können Sie in einer Blutgasanalyse schon sehen, ob eine Lungenembolie oder eine C-UPD hat?
Mit C-UPD kann eine niedrige Sauerstoffsättigung langsam erhöht werden.
Also bei einer C-UPD haben Sie eine hyperkapnische?
Ja, über die Hyperkapnische können wir schauen.
Oder ob eine hyperkapnische Hyperthekatastrophe hat.
Und bei der Lungenembolie kann die Beschwerden oder Erniedrigung der Sauerstoffsättigung schnell kommen.
Und es gibt keine respiratorische Alkaloase zu erhalten.
Das müssen Sie noch einmal durchlesen.
Aber Sie können das durchlesen, ob man in einer Blutgasse oder wie die an Lungenembolie aussieht.
Das müssen Sie noch einmal lesen.
Aber Sie sollten bei den Verdachten einer extraservierten C-UPD immer eine Blutgasanalyse machen.
Sie haben ja die Anamnese abgebrochen, um den Patienten Sauerstoff zu geben.
Dann müssten Sie sagen, ich breche die Anamnese jetzt ab, wir machen eine Blutgasanalyse und ich gebe Ihnen Sauerstoff oder keinen Sauerstoff.
Das ist wichtig.
BGA ist bei extraservierten C-UPD extrem wichtig.
Warum?
Weil wenn er schon sehr hohes CO2 hat und wenn Sie noch mehr Sauerstoff geben, zu viel, das ist auch nicht gut.
Dann vergisst er irgendwann zu atmen.
Aber BGA müssen Sie noch einmal durchlesen, wie eine BGA aussieht.
Falls es bei Ihnen in Bayern gefragt wird.
Was machen Sie therapeutisch?
Sie haben jetzt einen Röntgen gemacht, Sie haben eine BGA gemacht, Sie haben Degimere gemacht, Degimere sind negativ.
Sie haben Röntgen-Torax gemacht.
Sie haben gesehen, er hat keinen Ptomotorax, keine Herzvergrößerung, Fleralgus.
Sie haben die Diagnose extraservierte C-UPD gestellt.
Was geben Sie ihm therapeutisch?
Welche Medikamente?
Wir können mit Sauerstoffgabe anfangen.
Wenn der Patient gleichzeitig Fieber hat und eine Entzündung mit Entzündungsparameter erhöht.
Dann können wir Antibiotikum anfangen.
Mit C-UPD können wir kurz und lang wirksame B2-Agonisten einhalten.
Sie können Inhalationstherapie machen?
Ja, Inhalationstherapie, Glycocortico-stereotide.
Wie machen Sie die Glycocortico-stereotide?
Inhalative können wir geben.
Nur in einem Ativ?
Nein, nicht nur im Ativ.
In Trevinoz können wir noch einleiten.
Das müssen Sie nicht.
Sie können es machen, richtig.
Aber Sie können noch Peros geben.
Oral.
Oral, ja.
Sie können noch Prägnisolone oral geben.
Wir nennen das eine Cortison-Stoßtherapie.
Schon mal gehört?
Cortison-Stoßtherapie.
Stoßtherapie, ich nehme noch das.
Peros, das reicht aus.
Sie müssen nicht unbedingt Intravenös geben.
Sie können Intravenös geben, wenn Sie möchten.
In der Regel reicht es aber aus, wenn Sie Peros geben.
Ungefähr 40 mg pro Tag.
40 mg?
Ungefähr.
Für 5-7 Tage.
Dann können Sie entweder absetzen oder langsam ausschleichen.
Oral oder Intravenös?
Nicht Intravenös.
Wir nennen es Oral.
Intravenös ist in Deutschland sehr selten.
Es ist sehr selten.
Es ist eher oral.
Wegen Schmerzen können Sie Schmerztherapie einleiten.
Genau.
Sie haben gesagt, wenn Sie ein Entzündungszeichen haben,
können Sie natürlich auch Antibiotikum geben.
Wenn Sie davon ausgehen, ist es eine Infekt-exazibierte COPD.
Ich habe B2-Agonisten gesagt.
Aber ist das richtig für die COPD?
Halbutamol können Sie geben.
Dann können Sie auch natürlich die ...
Wie heißen die?
Natürlich können Sie zwei individuelle Labas geben.
Ormaterol, Salmaterol.
So etwas in der Art.
Das können Sie geben.
Wir können aber auch natürlich die Anticholinergiker geben.
Die Anticholinergiker geben.
Wahrscheinlich hat er die schon als Therapie.
Er hat den Namen vergessen.
Er hat die als Therapie.
Ja.
Was Sie vergessen haben zu fragen,
ist bei den Patienten, ob er bei einem Lungenfacharzt in Behandlung ist.
Und zweitens, welchen Grad COPD er hat.
Er hat Grad 1, Grad 2, Grad 3.
Goldstadion.
Gold 1, Gold 2, Gold 3.
Die Stadien, die kennt der Patienten meistens.
Das sollten Sie fragen.
Wenn Sie einen COPD-Patienten haben,
immer fragen, ist er regelmäßig bei einem Lungenfacharzt?
Und welchen COPD-Goldstufe hat er?
Entweder 1, 2, 3, 4 oder ABCW.
Kommt immer darauf an, welches man benutzt.
Ja.
Danke schön.
Gibt es sonst Fragen?
Murat Hocam.